The law of total probability
is another probability law
that gives you a way to reason
about cases, which we've
seen is a fundamental
technique for dealing
with all sorts of problems.
So the point of
cases, of course,
is that you can prove
a complicated thing
by breaking it up into, if
you're lucky, easy sub cases.
So here's the way to understand
the law of total probability
abstractly.
It starts off with set
theoretic reasonings.
Suppose that I have a set A
embedded in some larger sample
space S. So A is
really an event,
but we're just going to
think of it as a set.
Now suppose that
I have three sets,
B1, B2, and B3 that
partition the sample space.
That is B1, B2, and B3
three don't overlap.
They're disjoined,
and everything
is in one of those three sets.
So there's a picture of
B1, B2, and B3, cutting up
the whole sample
space S, represented
by the square or rectangle.
Now of course, these
three sets that
cut up the whole
space, willy nilly
cut up the set A
into three pieces.
The first piece is the
points in A that are in B1.
The second piece is the
point in A that are in B2.
And the third is the
points in A that are in B3.
So that's why we a
basic set theoretic
identity that says that
as long as B1, B2, and B3
have the property, that they're
union is in the universe.
Everything.
And they are pairwise
disjoined, then
any set A is equal to the
union of the part of A
that's in B1, the part
of A that's in B2,
the part of A that's in B3.
And this is a disjoint union,
because the B's don't overlap.
That means that if I was
talking about cardinality,
I could add them up.
But in terms of probability,
I can apply the sum rule
for probabilities and discover
that the probability of A
is simply the probability of B1
intersection A, B2 intersection
A, B3 intersection A.
Now the most useful form of
the law of total probabilities
is when you replace this
intersection, B1 intersection
A, by the conditional
probability using the product
rule-- so let's replace it
by the probability of A given
B1 times the probability of B1.
That's another formula
for B1 intersection A.
And if I do that with
the rest of them,
I now have the law of
total probability stated
in the usual way in terms
of conditional probabilities
where it's most useful.
Now I did it for three sets.
But it obviously works for
any finite number of sets.
As a matter of fact, it works
fine for any countable union
of sets.
If I have a partition
of the sample space S
in to B0, B1, and
so on-- a partition
with a countable
number of blocks-- then
it's still the case that
the probability of A
is equal by the sum
rule to the probability
of these disjoint
pieces, the parts of A
that are in each of
the different blocks
of the partition.
And reformulating that as
a conditional probability,
I get the rule that
the probability of A
is the sum over all possible i
of the probability of A given
Bi times the probability of Bi.
And that basic rule
is one and we're
going to get a lot of
mileage out of when
we turn in the next segment
to analyze and understand
the results of tests that
are maybe unreliable.